i'm matthew i'm a third year phd student
at carnegie mellon i work with heather
miller unfortunately heather couldn't be
here today so you'll have to settle for
just me
i'm going to be talking about how to
make oops
and talk about how to make web apps
collaborative with composable crdts
so first things first when i say
collaborative apps i'm thinking of
programs like these you know google docs
is probably the classic example but then
we've got all sorts of other things you
know shared notepads shared whiteboards
and i broadly
or more specifically i consider these to
be basically any app where you have a
small group of users working together to
edit some shared state
okay and these apps are great right we
use these all the time there's actually
good for remote work and stuff like that
so let's say inspired by this greatness
you want to make your own collaborative
apps
in particular let's say that you have an
app that's not collaborative yet but you
want to add collaboration
so here's a running example it's a
simple recipe book app you've got your
list of recipes on the left you can
click on a recipe to view its
ingredients and edit them this is a
really simple app it's like 200 lines of
typescript plus some html and css i got
it off of codepen and then added a few
more features
so yeah it's a it's a static app it just
runs in the user's browser there's no
servers or anything fancy and it's the
kind of thing that you could probably
make in a weekend just put on your
personal website
should i move this at all this is okay
okay
uh yeah anyway so this is something you
could probably make in like a weekend
put it on your personal website and just
forget about it okay but now we want to
add collaboration how are you going to
go about that well you're probably
thinking we're going to need some full
stack architecture right we're going to
run some servers in the cloud set up
sync protocols user accounts security
we're going to need some money to run
the servers essentially becomes really
popular you know you know if you've got
a million users it's going to be a
decent amount of money maybe you'll need
a company to manage all that
basically at this point you're thinking
of quitting your job and starting a
startup all just to add collaboration to
this app that's a lot different from
what we started with in a single user
case where you could just make in a
weekend put it up and forget about it
okay
so here's sort of summary you know
compared to a single user app it's a lot
harder to develop and deploy and then
there's downsides from the user
perspective too right they lose the
privacy of their data for all you know
you might just be taking all their
secret family recipes and you're going
to publish them into books somewhere
there's no guarantee of longevity for
their data or the app itself once it's
in the cloud it's not going to work
offline but of course it's collaborative
also from the perspective of open source
i'm a big fan of the open source
movement but when you have a
collaborative app even if the source
code is public it's not really like
someone can just download the source
make a little change and then republish
it
with the same quality as the original
right because if you want to republish
it you're going to go have to go through
all this trouble of making all this or
renting all the servers again
but we're ambitious we'd like to get all
the green check marks we want all the
good properties of single user
collaborative apps
but without the um but while also
getting collaboration yes sorry all the
good properties of single user
non-cooperative apps but we also want to
add collaboration
the question is what technology can we
use to make this possible or is this
even possible
as you can probably guess i wouldn't be
here if i didn't think this was possible
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
how i think we can do it
so the core idea comes out of the work
of martin clittman and his collaborators
at true data and you can switch if you
if you don't know martin he's a
researcher at cambridge university i was
lucky to work with him
he was one of my info advisors when i
was in cambridge three years ago
and the basic idea that came out of this
line of work is that instead of making
collaborative apps centered around the
server where the server is the single
point of truth and the clients are just
single or thin clients instead we are
going to store our app state in
client-side conflict-free replicated
data types or crdts
and then we're going to let those do all
the work of collaboration
so what this looks like is if you have
you know one of our ingredients the
ingredient carrot then if grandma here
changes the ingredient then her own
browser is going to call
text.insert4o where text instead of a
normal string it's now going to be a
text crdt
so what text does under the hood when
this change happens it's going to send
messages to everyone else looking at the
same recipe
and this message basically encodes the
effect encodes the fact that she's
inserted the letter o everyone else
wants to get these messages their own
copy of the text string will update to
express it so that way we get
collaboration
and the neat properties of crdt's well
there's a lot of neat things about them
but particular the first thing is that
each client crdt is considered a true
copy of the collaborative state so each
client has a true copy of the recipe
book it's not like they're just
listening to some servers true copy and
they can use this always so for example
in particular it'll still work offline
and then you can sync up changes with
everyone else later
yeah more generally clients can sync up
with each other whenever and however as
long as two clients can contact each
other and send messages they can
collaborate
okay
yeah so then the particular thing i want
to talk about today is a new library
called collabs that we just released on
npm and it's a typescript library that
provides these crdts i actually i like
the more what i think about is a more
general term of collaborative data
structures just because there's things
that could work that aren't generally
considered crdts
like certain operational transform part
types but anyway i'll probably use these
terms sort of interchangeably
and
let's see yes then what this library
gives you is it gives you collaborative
versions of ordinary data types that you
can use in the browser like instead of
using a string you'll use a
collaborative text and then if you
change this type on one client it'll all
automatically show up on everyone else's
clients do and likewise you know maps
arrays all sorts of data types
okay so then when you're using collabs
you end up adopting the following
architecture so at the top of your
network stack you have your apps front
end so like that that single user app i
showed you before the sorry the recipe
book app i showed you before
and then internally instead of using
normal data structures to store the
state you'll use the collaborative data
structures from collabs okay
and then to in order to work these you
need a way to actually contact other
users so you have to provide a network
and this network has to guarantee
broadcast messaging basically when one
user sends a message everyone else
should receive it eventually but it
doesn't really matter how
in particular there's no requirements
that the messages are delivered in order
or that they're delivered within a
certain amount of time it can take you
know days even a year if you wanted
and the collaborative data structures
will still work they'll still converge
to the same collaborative state
and technically they're eventually
consistent
so what this lacks network requirement
lets you do is it lets you use basically
any network you can think of to connect
the collaborators together it doesn't
just have to be your own apps server
that's a model and a
monolithic platform
so in particular you can still use a
server if you want but it doesn't have
to be a specific thing it could be some
generic messaging server that can work
for all sorts of apps which means you
don't have to deploy it yourself someone
else can do it for you
you can also use something cooler you
could use you know webrtc ipfs
you could use some group checks group
chat protocol like matrix
sneaker net you know send usb sticks in
the mail and the other cool thing is
that you can change out your network at
any time like maybe you decide the
server you're currently using isn't good
enough or it goes away or it costs too
much or whatever you can just switch
your conversation over to a different
one as long as you make sure not to lose
any messages in transit you'll be okay
and the clients will continue having the
true copies of the state so i think that
can help to prevent a lot of the ills
around vendor lock-in and things like
this
okay
so of course using our library isn't
completely trivial you'll still have to
do some stuff to your single user app to
make it collaborative
so the first step is to replace each
state with collabs versions of each type
so for example
in the single user version we have this
class ingredient which describes a
single ingredient like you know three
cups of flour
it has a text string or we just convert
that into a collaborative text
the amount is a number we convert it
into this fancy number that i'll mention
later the units return it to a last
writer wins register
that just means that you know if two
people try to change the units at the
same time it'll just pick one based on
wall clock time
okay and there's a table in the docs
that helps you with this conversion
and we have to do this to a few classes
to do some boilerplate and then connect
things up to the actual gui and then
once that's done you can just publish
your app as static files on the web you
don't have to launch a bunch of cloud
servers or anything like that
and in fact for the demos i'm going to
show i just push the files to a public
github repo because that's the easiest
thing i can figure out
okay so that's how to make the app
collaborative and
oh yes yeah so the total effort is we
started with 211 lines of typescript we
end up with about 500 uh that's kind of
a lot i would argue the true number is
for like this 300 here once you factor
out some re reusable parts that'll
probably just publish separately so
those you won't have to write the next
time you make a collaborative app
and this is they're in this github repo
here i'll put a link at the end
and
yeah so now let's see this in action
so here you might recognize from the
third slider so this is our
collaborative recipe book and if i
enter something in here
i've sort of suggestedly opened this and
two windows at once and we can indeed
see that once i update one of the
windows the changes show up the other
one
i can change
three
cups of chicken
change the pie crust to account instead
of a cup and these will eventually show
up on the other side
it's a bit slow because even though
these tabs are on the same computer i am
using a server just to demonstrate that
this really is internet connected it
could equally well be very far apart it
would still work
and it's going through the 4g signal on
my phone so it's a bit slow
anyway yeah that's our collaborative
recipe book now you have a place where
you know the whole family can compile
their secret family recipes together
edit them no matter how far apart they
are
and yeah i think the coolest thing about
this is the thing that's kind of hard to
see the fact that i was able to deploy
this recipe book just by pushing a file
to github not having to do any extra
effort all the networking instead is
handled by this group chat which is
happening in
matrix is element client you can see if
i type a message on the left it shows up
on the right so this is just a normal
group chat but it has the ability to
plug in arbitrary apps and send messages
through the group chat
and i use matrix to do this um i don't
know if you've heard of it but it's
basically it's like a group chat
protocol that's more of an open standard
as opposed to some monolithic platform
like whatsapp that means anyone can
write a server anyone can write a client
and they all interoperate together just
like with email
it's a bit like a bit more open than
what you're used to
um
yeah and this means that you know if my
recipe app becomes very popular i don't
have to worry about scaling it's matrix
faster scale i just have to keep that
file up on github for other people to
use
okay
now one thing i promised in the talk
abstract was to show you end-to-end
decrypted collaboration we're actually
doing that already
it's a bit small to see here but this
gray box says encryption enabled
messages in this room are and then
encrypted so everything that's being
sent through the matrix group chat is
encrypted on the one client and then
sent an encrypted form to the network
decrypted by my collaborators so that
means anything i type into this app is
effectively secret
for instance i could type you know like
my
email password is
hunter 2 okay i don't have to worry that
some server admin or like a network
adversary somewhere i saw someone taking
a picture of that
is
is going to look at this password and
you know use it to hack me or whatever
the only people who can see this are me
and my collaborators
well of course also everyone here
so get rid of that
okay so that's an encrypted
collaboration maybe the recipe book is a
bit of a silly example but you can
imagine this is useful for things like
you know rich text editors if you want
to use google docs but you don't trust
google with your data because it's
sensitive or for legally compliance
reasons then you can use an end
encrypted network host like this instead
okay that's one demo i had also promised
to demo
lan or server free collaboration um and
again this is possible using crdts
because they don't care about message
order it's okay if like you know two
people sync up now and they sync up with
everyone else later
so to demonstrate that i am going to
disconnect the
4g on my phone
now my laptop's connected to my phone as
a hotspot so they can talk to each other
but we're cut off from the rest of the
internet
and if we're extremely lucky
i'll be able to use my phone
to connect directly to this app
let's see it's a bit flaky sometime i'm
using this lib peer to peer which i
think is a bit of an alpha state
um
yeah it doesn't look like this is
working for now
okay so it's working when i tried it 10
minutes ago i don't know what's
happening but let's just open this app
into windows on my laptop
wait for it
okay and now you can see this is a lot
snappier than it was
before when i was using a matrix to do
the collaboration that's because it's
just sending messages
through
the through localhost instead of all the
way to a server and back but in
principle this would work if you had two
different computers on a lan i just
don't have two computers here right now
they would find each other automatically
using live peer-to-peers multicast dns
plugin
and what that means is that you can
continue collaborating even if you know
you're on a plane with some other people
or maybe you're out doing field work
somewhere you don't have a connection
with a broader internet but you can
still talk to each other
and things will just work how you expect
them to
and as a final demo we don't just have
this silly little recipe app you can
make more complicated things too
i mean it's a bit rough around the edges
because i don't know css but um
so this is a demo that sort of
incorporates like a shared whiteboard
shared notes that have rich text in them
and also you can plug in arbitrary other
collaborative apps so here i'm doing uh
something that i've seen my fiance use
it's like a horse jean editor you can
click on the genes and see what the
horse would look like if you change them
it's just like a it's a silly niche
thing you can make you know family trees
out of it see what their horses are
going to look like
i use it as an example because it's it's
such a specific thing i wouldn't expect
someone to go to all the trouble of
making a platform just to deploy this
app as a collaborative version but with
collabs because we outsource the network
to you know matrix or other sources we
can just take the single user version of
this app and add collaboration to it
fairly easily and indeed the original
version of this app it comes from an
artist named jennifer hoffman who
painted all these pretty pictures and
put it on our web page as just a static
page with html and javascript left it
there for 10 years or so i just took a
weekend to download it and turn it into
using collabs
okay um so that's the demos
yeah so hopefully i've shown you that at
least in principle it is possible to
make these collaborative apps that get
you know the good properties for both
developers and users and in principle
could be open source as well
so for the rest of the talk i want to
give a bit more detail about our library
in particular try to justify you to you
why are we making a new crdt library and
why might you consider using it instead
of one of the alternatives
because if you're familiar with crdts
you might object and say like well crdts
have been around for a long time there's
already implementations why do we need a
new one okay
so yeah you're right that crdts have
been around for a while in theory since
around 2008 maybe even earlier in
practice we've seen nosql data stores
like react in bloom around 2014 more
recently ygs and auto merge do the same
sort of like local first peer-to-peer
ready collaboration in the browser using
crdts and there's other collaboration
libraries that happened those either
server though
and basically the idea is that the
the special properties collabs are these
three things so it's flexible and
extensible it's composable and when you
use it you can keep your
your local for your original single user
data model and type safety and i'll go
over what all these means on the next
few slides
okay first off flexible and extensible
by that i mean that you can add new
types of the library so if you're using
collabs in an app and you need some data
structure that we don't have yet you can
just implement it yourself use it within
your app maybe publish it as a third
party extension
so you're not stuck just with the things
that we've happened to implemented even
though this might sound obvious for like
a collections data structures library
it's a bit tricky to do with replicated
data structures
and it's actually a somewhat rare
feature that you can add new
collaborative data types without forking
the library and changing its source code
this is useful because you know maybe
tomorrow someone will come out with a
cool new crdt algorithm like this paper
by martin klepman on moving elements and
lists here dts it lets you do useful
things like you know if we were to move
ingredients in the recipe app while
someone else was editing the ingredients
text you want to keep both of these
changes instead of just destroying one
or making a copy of things or whatever
so that's what this paper does
so yeah if you wanted to wanted to you
could add this to the library
um
and more generally this flexibility
means that the library can sort of age
gracefully we're not stuck with the
crdts of today even if you know i don't
maintain the library very much and add
new types to it other people can keep
contributing
so now this paper it didn't come out
tomorrow it came out about a year and a
half ago at papa 2020 so um we've
already implemented within the library
so sorry if you're planning on going
home and implementing this tonight we
sort of beat you to the punch there
um as far as i'm aware we're the only
library to have included this type so
far i haven't heard of any other
implementations yet anyway hopefully
that will be less of a problem in the
future
um
okay so yeah i've told you you can add
new types but now you might be objecting
and saying like wait i've heard crdts
are really hard i don't want to have to
write my own types that's for
distributed systems experts maybe people
with a math background because they have
to prove correctness and all that
so the good news is that we also provide
composition techniques that make it
easier to build new collaborative data
structures and just building them from
scratch of course you can build them
from scratch but if you use these
techniques instead then you can reach
avoid repeating yourself and also their
correctness property is composed too so
if you start with two correct things and
glue them together as long as you follow
the rules you'll still get like eventual
consistency and convergence and all that
so for example
when i say composition i'm thinking of
things like this this is from the paper
i mentioned on the last slide basically
the way martin describes this movable
list is to say instead of using a list
directly we are going to represent the
state as a collaborative set this aw is
set here and it's going to contain pairs
value comma position where the position
is something that you can mutate
and you need it you mutate it using a
last writer wins register which means
just like if two people try to move the
thing at the same time it'll pick one
based on wall clock time
okay
so yeah this is a this is a very elegant
description
by martin and we can implement it in our
library basically by directly
translating this compositional
construction
so this isn't the actual code this is
more like a summary of how they
implemented it but basically you have
your collaborative set it's made of list
entries
i guess i should say list entry in the
class at the bottom there by the way
each entry is made of the value and the
position register and then you also have
this position source object which does
the list part of things of like giving
you new positions and sorting them
so this is really nice first off the
correctness follows rather quickly like
this collaborative set is never going to
be different on two users devices
they're always going to see the same
values we don't have to worry about
things diverging there and also we get
to reuse the existing implementation
like this dense local list class that
probably gave me the most trouble out of
any class in the whole library so i'm
really glad i don't have to implement it
again
okay
that was composition uh but now if
looking at this i think martin almost
makes it sound too easy to implement and
then you're looking at our source code
you're saying oh you haven't done
anything interesting we just glued a set
and a dense local list together by
putting them next to each other that's
not a very exciting composition okay
maybe that's true but you can do more
exciting compositions as well
and to describe one of those
i'm going to
set a scenario so the scenario is it's
christmas eve you want to make
gingerbread cookies for santa okay you
pull up your family shared recipe book
and you see the gingerbread cookie
recipe it starts with three cups of
flour two eggs half a teaspoon of baking
powder etc
okay so you're looking at that youth
sink okay
i also want some cookies for myself not
just some for santa so i'm going to
double the recipe we have a scale recipe
button that lets you do this really
easily so now it has six cups of flour
four eggs one teaspoon baking powder
meanwhile your cousin has had the same
idea they pull up their copy of the
shared recipe book you know a thousand
miles away and they think
instead of making the cookies as is
they're going to reduce the flour a
little bit so they're a bit less cakey
so they said flour to 2.8 cups
and now for whatever reason the
internet's kind of flaky right now you
and your cousin don't immediately sync
up which is fine
and then later
the
um yeah later you sync up the recipes
converge and you know everything your
your two views will converge so now
you're making the recipe you put in your
four eggs your one teaspoon of baking
powder all the other doubled ingredients
you get to flour it says 2.8 cups okay
you add 2.8 cups of flour and then you
bake the cookies and they'll probably
come out looking something like this
kind of a gooey mess i haven't tried
this so i don't know for sure but
basically they've got half as much flour
as they're supposed to
here we've got this 2.8 cups of flour
and why did this happen well in this
this hypothetical scenario basically
whatever collaborative data structures
library you've chosen is it saw that
someone said flour to six cups someone
else said flour to 2.8 cups but didn't
really assign any meaning to the fact
that you doubled the recipe it's just
using a last writer winch register for
these so then when it sees this conflict
it picks one arbitrarily it happened to
pick your cousin's change which is a bit
unlucky for you
okay
so let's see what happens if we
do something
fancier so how could we have prevented
this accident
i'm going to oops
go to another demo here so here we've
got the start of this gingerbread recipe
there's like 10 more ingredients that
aren't shown here
and i'm going to use these debug
controls to connect the one window from
the internet so the left window is us
we're going to double the recipe
okay
the right window is our cousin we're
going to chain decrease the flour just a
little bit
okay and now when we connect things
should see that the flour has gone to
5.6 cups
this is basically what the user is going
to intuitively expect right we've
doubled the recipe it was also changed a
little bit so we should double that
change
okay
so under the hood this is using a
composition technique called the
semi-direct product which i wrote about
in a paper with heather and chris
nickeljohn at icfp last year so back
then it was a theoretical
theoretical construction we've
implemented within the library
just sort of the point of the library to
start off with is we wanted to implement
the semi-direct product and then we saw
that the api we had created was really
terrible so we thought how can we
improve this just kind of went from
there
yeah basically this semi-direct product
it lets you take two sets of operations
on the same state and combine them under
certain conditions
in a way that makes sense so for
instance here we've combined the
doubling operation and the set operation
on a register in the way that makes
intuitive sense
okay
so that's composition
and the last special property of our
library is that you can keep your data
model and its type safety so here on the
left
hopefully you can read it i have the
class ingredient from the original
single user recipe up or a rest of the
app you can see a fan of you know the
text the amount the units the
constructor sets values
then to make this collaborative the
first step is we want to replace object
with collaborative object in the
ingredient class okay
and then we replace each of these
instance fields which is with its
collaborative version
um you know string becomes ctex etc but
all these instance fields are still
typed right if you ask the last writer
wins register of type unit for its value
it's going to be a unit
and then we have to do some boilerplate
in the constructor some more boilerplate
this is basically just telling the
library like hey these types exist you
should connect them to the network
and the nice thing here is that we still
have a class we still have types those
are both nice we can still use
encapsulation and things like this
and again this might seem sort of
obvious for a collections library that
you would get these properties but
actually it's
it's sort of rare when using crdts
because
i guess the the existing libraries they
tend to look more like nosql data stores
where you know you have a store you put
some data in it as json or as
unstructured maps and lists then when
you get back get it back out again you
kind of forgotten that structure
so as in our library we tried to let you
use classes
okay
um yeah so that's it i think i talked a
bit too fast so we'll have lots of time
for questions that's our library collabs
you can download it on npm look at the
source code on github
all the demos i showed today there's
github repos they're linked on my
personal website which you can find in
the talk description page
and i just finally i'd like to
acknowledge
all the students who have worked on the
library over the past year or so they've
been helping out with some of the core
stuff looking at the api
working on demos that got integrated
into some of the stuff you saw today um
yeah
so yeah that's it thank you
uh yes we haven't looked into that yet i
think in theory it should be possible
using the same sort of ideas like in
google proto buffs where you know you
would have
um handlers would like ignore fields
they don't recognize or you know in
particular if you have like an object
and it sees a message for some instance
field it doesn't know about it'll just
ignore it um yeah it's definitely
something we want to look at in the
future
yeah the question was to show how the
gingerbread example is implemented
to find the right report
and
it's this class here
let's see so first we have to define the
multiplication part which is this mult
number um so that's like a primitive
thing where you just like send messages
but it's very simple you just you know
send the number as
a byte array then on the other side you
multiply your value by that number
so that's one component the other
component is the last writer wins
register which comes built into the
library
and then to combine these let's see
how can i
distill this
you basically so we make a register
whose value is a multi-number so like a
mutable number that you can multiply and
whenever you set the value it's it just
becomes a new multi-number that you can
multiply
and then when you multiply it there's
two things that happen first you
multiply all the numbers that you know
about and then you also use the
semi-derived product to
basically tell you are there any new
numbers that appeared concurrently to
the multiplication you multiply those as
well
so that happens like
in here you basically send a message
saying like everyone please multiply
um all the numbers you know about where
they happen concurrently
it's a bit hard to show
in code like this
uh-huh yeah so the question was do we
see a path to making letting the users
define how to resolve conflicts
i'm not sure this isn't something i've
thought about i guess it is tricky
because there are still
correctness guarantees you have to
maintain like sometimes users might want
something to happen in the face of
conflicts that's just like it doesn't
make sense mathematically
um yeah i guess that would be the ideal
though if you could just you know look
at the thing and say this is what i
expect to happen make it happen
um
i like the like these things
let's see
so there's two pieces here
there so this is the internal app
um
the main thing you do
to set up the collaboration so at the
bottom you have to get a run time from a
library somehow just like the entry
point then you register your data types
which appear up top
so this isn't actually connected to the
network at all
the network instead this is sort of like
a generic network agnostic app you plug
this into a different thing which then
talks to matrix or like the network of
your choosing
i can try to find that if you want to be
in a different folder though
oops
large
oops
um
yeah so this is an example like how to
talk to matrix we have this interface
you have to implement that's a broadcast
network and then when you ask to send a
message it just talks to the
this api put out by a matrix which is
like how to talk to their group chat and
just pipe the message through
and then there's some like you set up
around this
oh if you want to know about the
peer-to-peer demo that's using lib p2p
the clients find each other using
multicast dns and then establish gcp
connections and just gossip over those
uh yeah the question was does it make it
it's possible to make a default to local
area network um yeah i think the the the
demo is set up now it should just work
if you're on a local area network where
you know peer-to-peer connections aren't
banned it's like a normal home network
um that should just work here i was
trying to use the phone hotspot because
i doubt the conference wi-fi would let
me make peer-to-peer connections
yeah i guess one of the more generally
one of the things we haven't done is to
make like you know a desktop app or
browser app that sort of incorporates
all possible networks and handles you
know retrying messages and stuff like
that would be something that would be
really useful especially if you could
make it like comprehensible to
non-technical users of like you know how
to choose your network and stuff like
that
i guess our focus is more on like making
that possible
uh what's next that's a good question i
guess there's a lot of like stuff to
clean up just like technical debt to
take care of take care of
um
yeah i remember i had something i was
thinking of doing next
oh yeah i guess one thing yeah this
feature is to make it like more actually
useful i still consider this in like an
alpha state so for example we have the
ability to save the state of an app like
including all the stuff you need to
continue collaborating we just haven't
actually integrated into the demos and
have them actually you know save the
state to a file occasionally and load it
back later that's probably the next
thing
yeah i think it should be pretty
flexible i know
i think both auto merge and ygs or maybe
just auto merge
the some other libraries that do similar
things they're originally written in
javascript they've been converting to
rust and trying to use webassembly to
run it that way
um
yeah it's basically it's just data
structures passing messages over the
network
yeah if that's it then
i guess thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you